stuffed shells a la vodka ultimate comfy  cozy eats now let's make it start by  cooking 20 shells in salted water one  minute shy about the packet suggests  reserving some pasta water add ricotta  parm mozzarella flat leaf parsley pepper  salt grated garlic and one egg to a bowl  mix and set aside next saute shallot and  minced garlic for a few minutes then add  butter tomato paste red chili flakes and  cook until the paste turns a deep Rusty  color add vodka and stir until the  liquid is reduced by about half slowly  add cream and then lots of freshly  grated parm add some of that reserved  pasta water and give it a nice stir then  pipe The Filling into those pretty  little shells and place them in a single  layer in the baking dish top with  remaining sauce and mozzarella bake  covered for 20 minutes then 15 minutes  uncovered serve and enjoy